[Música]
la adversidad
puede ser una aliada y si pudiéramos
transformar la adversidad en una aliada
para nosotros cuantos de los que estamos
aquí hemos vivido alguna situación de
adversidad a lo largo de nuestra vida
esto es muy común y forma parte de la
vida lo que yo me pregunto es hasta qué
punto la adversidad puede convertirse en
el impulsor o la impulsora de un festín
de calidad de un primer paso de un
impulso para que genere un cambio en
nuestra vida porque supongo que
cualquier primer paso empieza con un
impulso a ese impulso a veces es
generado por personas que sin darnos
cuenta generan un gran cambio en
nuestras vidas esas personas es lo que
yo llamo auster makers personas que de
repente generan un primer cambio que
luego mirando en perspectiva compruebas
que ha transformado tu vida
reflexionando acerca de que first makers
yo conozco potentes en la vida a mi
alrededor dentro de las personas a las
que a las que conozco surgió la historia
de adán adam que hoy es adulto no pero
pero como niño cuando vayan ver a un
niño
experimentó la visita de una first maker
de alto impacto de alto impacto de
sofres maker fue su hermana esther
esther es una persona que vino al mundo
para
entregarnos quizás algunas valiosas
lecciones de vida a los que hemos tenido
la oportunidad de conocerlas sterbik al
mundo con un 70% de discapacidad y
cuando vienes al mundo con un 70 por
ciento discapacidad la vida no es a
adversidad la vida es un desafío
permanente permanente permanente a dan
cuenta que la pregunta más importante
que nunca a nadie le hizo en la vida
hasta el momento se la hizo su hermana
mirándole un día a los ojos y
preguntándole por qué tú eres así yo así
porque tú lo tienes todo
y yo por qué yo no
supongo que esta es una de esas
preguntas que se te clava por dentro y
que te descoloca absolutamente y que
quizás también abre una rendija a través
de la cual
uno empieza a mirar la vida de forma
diferente
aram
tuvo que enfrentarse probablemente a su
primer gran first ed que fue superar el
síndrome del hermano shannon esto es
algo que le sucede a algunos hermanos de
personas con discapacidad que se sienten
culpables por el hecho de ser normales y
para paliar el sufrimiento de sienten
sus hermanos con discapacidad al
compararse con los hermanos sanos el
hermano sano lo que hace es generarse
problemas dificultades y limitaciones
que reduzcan la distancia entre su
hermano con discapacidad y él o ella
con la idea de que cuanto peor usted
mejor
aunque esa es una idea que por lo
general al final es mala para todos es
mala para todos
ahora me experimento muchas maneras de d
somatizar el estrés emocional que esa
situación de adversidad generó en su
vida por ejemplo el cuenta que hasta los
10 años se hacía pis en la cama cuando
los amigos le invitaban a ir a su casa a
pasar la noche él siempre tenía que
inventar alguna historia para no revelar
su secreto los médicos todos los que le
vieron le dijeron que estaba perfecto
ningún médico anticipó que quizás no era
capaz de digerir el nivel de estrés
emocional que esa circunstancia de
adversidad estaba generando el subidón
tuvo que cambiar muchas veces de
ciudades de colegios de amigos etc etc
sus padres iban moviéndose de una ciudad
a otra para encontrar soluciones a los
problemas de formar así que tuvo que
irse a vivir incluso con unos familiares
durante un tiempo para poder tener una
cierta estabilidad que le permitiera
asistir al colegio y
adam descubrió el miedo a sentirse solo
y descubrió también el miedo del cuenta
a la sensación de sentirme excluido
rechazado porque adán tenía un detalle
que lo hacía diferente en muchos casos
de forma visible a muchos de los niños
con los que quería crear una primera
relación en esos nuevos colegios y es
que alan tenía orejas de soplillo tenía
las orejas así muy hacia adelante y
entonces esa diferencia tan fácilmente
reconocible
con facilidad invitaba a generar alguna
broma
que no hacía gracia a todos
investigaciones como las de la obvia y
sin ver desde la universidad de ucla
muestran que se activan las filtraciones
en el cerebro cuando una persona siente
dolor social se siente rechazado
rechazada
se activa la piel es que cuando uno
siente dolor físico cuando tú dices esto
que me has dicho esto que me han hecho
me ha dolido lo que dices
es literal literal además se dio cuenta
también de qué
cuando un ser humano está en situación
vulnerable
una mirada más esto
y un brazo
puede marcar una gran diferencia en la
vida porque los seres humanos
tenemos un gran poder
solamente que a veces no lo utilizamos y
descubrió también la frustración que
muchas veces se siente cuando no tienes
respuestas
porque él recuerda que salía con su
armario con sus padres a veces a pasear
y la gente se paraba por la calle y
miraba a su hermana como si fuera un
raro y su hermana lloraba a veces
gritaba a veces se enfadaba
y la gente no quería hacerle daño aunque
se lo hacía
y llegaba un momento en el que daban
igual las explicaciones lo único que
podía acompañar
a esa situación a veces era
un abrazo
este es un gran poder que tenemos los
seres humanos solo que para acompañar a
otro ser humano en el dolor y ayudarle a
transmutar lo es necesario ser capaz de
sostener
tu propio dolor
así que los contaré que derivó la
historia pero yo estoy seguro que todos
estamos aquí hemos tenido algún test
baker en nuestra vida lo que ha generado
un impacto importante y que eso ha
cambiado la dirección de nuestra vida
estoy absolutamente seguro porque la
adversidad y los desafíos forman parte
de la vida de hecho todos necesitamos en
muchos casos un cierto empujón una
cierta fricción para salir a la vida y
sin esa fricción en muchos casos es
difícil poder vivir nos moldean nos
define nos ayuda a avanzar múltiples
investigaciones muestran como las
personas que enfrentan la adversidad en
lugar de mirar hacia otro lado intentar
escapar de ella gozan a posteriori de
mayor satisfacción con la vida mayor
salud física y mayor salud emocional hay
un estudio muy interesante de este
doctor richard davidson por ejemplo
experto en neurociencia que muestra como
las personas con más capacidad para
sostener la adversidad tienen más
conexiones entre dos áreas de su cerebro
la corteza prefrontal izquierda
vinculada a la motivación positiva de
los comportamientos proactivos y
desalientan las cerebrales relacionadas
con activar la respuesta de estrés para
luchar ruido bloquearlos cuando nos
sentimos
las personas con más conexiones de estas
dos áreas son capaces de encontrar con
más facilidad aprendizaje utilidad y
algún tipo de beneficio futuro en la
adversidad que tanto cuesta sostener y
que en muchos casos tanto cuentas atrás
cuesta tu cuesta atravesar acá la
cuestión es que todos los seres humanos
somos capaces de entrenar y mejorar la
conexión entre estas áreas porque
nuestro cerebro es plástico la
neuroplasticidad nos permite desarrollar
nuestras capacidades y esta es una
ventaja muy importante en la vida hay un
estudio que me fascina de marchi de la
universidad de buffalo que trata de
indagar y de explorar cuál es el impacto
de la adversidad en la vida de los seres
humanos
sin y tomar unos 2000 2.000 personas que
en eeuu que intenta que reflejen a toda
la población mayor de edad de eeuu y de
sal seguimiento durante cuatro años pero
antes de empezar el seguimiento les
invita a rellenar un cuestionario con 37
grandes sucesos negativos grandes
sucesos enfermedad grave muerte de un
familiar cercano problemas graves
financieros etc y las personas tienen
que marcar cuántas de esas cosas les han
sucedido antes de empezar el seguimiento
de los cuatro años lo que sucede al
obtener los resultados es que
el número de sucesos
restantes han sucedido a la vida en
muchos casos no hay donde escapar antes
o después la adversidad va a llegar a
nuestras vidas hay un 8 por ciento de
participantes que por el momento todavía
no ha sufrido ninguna situación de
adversidad
y las personas a las que la vida les ha
golpeado más duramente les ha golpeado
71 veces
mucha mucha adversidad
sí que se hace una gran pregunta y la
pregunta es puede la adversidad que
predice la adversidad en la experiencia
del ser humano
y más recursos o menos recursos más
fortaleza o más debilidad
y los resultados al acabar los cuatro
años se colocan en una 1 y en esa hubo
tenemos en un extremo mínimo nivel de
adversidad
en el otro extremo máximo nivel de
adversidad resulta que después de los 4
años las personas que están mejor de
salud física de salud emocional y con
más satisfacción en sus vidas
estar en el medio
las personas que están peor de salud
física salud emocional de satisfacción
con la vida están en los extremos
nada de adversidad
no nos fortalece
nos debilita muchísima adversidad hace
nuestra vida más desafiante pero
suficiente adversidad nos prepara nos
cocina nos moldea para llegar a ser
ya sé que es tremendamente difícil tomar
perspectiva cuando estamos atravesando
una situación difícil
y recordar que tal vez esa adversidad se
convertirá en un recurso en el futuro
para que podamos estar mejor ya no se
que es difícil
aunque también es verdad que qué cosas
hay en la vida que merezcan enormemente
la pena y sean fáciles así que la
cuestión es si podemos también entrenar
nuestra resiliencia de algún modo
y aquí descubrí un estudio que le
fascinó hace un tiempo de dicho de la
universidad northwestern que estudió
precisamente a niños en entornos en eeuu
muy desfavorecidos en familias muy
desestructuradas entornos muy pobres
muchas dificultades muchas densidad
desde el primer momento ella descubrió
que habían niños que en lugar de
quedarse atrapados ahí eran capaces de
salir de esa situación y salir
fortalecidos y que era lo que compartían
todos esos niños cuál era el factor
común que les hacía más resilientes como
seres humanos ella descubrió que lo que
hacían esos niños era responder con la
actitud que se llama de cambio y
persistencia la actitud de cambio tiene
que ver con dos factores el primero es
aceptar la situación de desafío en lugar
de intentar escapar a veces con
comportamientos autodestructivos a
lugares donde no hay donde escapar
aceptar no quiere decir resignarse
quiere decir tener la inteligencia
suficiente como para no hacer más
difícil algo que ya es difícil enfocar
la atención y la energía en aquello que
sí depende de ti en lugar de en aquello
que tú no puedes cambiar y el segundo
factor de la actitud de cambio que
presentarán estos niños tiene que ver
con que enfocaban su atención en tratar
de extraer un aprendizaje de esa
situación que puedo aprender de una esta
intensidad que estoy viviendo cuál es la
utilidad para mí que puedo aprender de
esto y el segundo factor
de la actitud con la que estos niños
respondían era el factor
de persistencia el factor de
persistencia tenía que ver con que estos
niños tener un optimismo absoluto con
respecto a que la situación antes o
después mejoraría tardaría más tardaría
menos pero mejoraría
y el segundo factor de la actitud de
persistencia era que estos niños
consideraban que de alguna manera aún
sin saber cómo esa experiencia adversa
contribuiría
a su propósito en realidad
sería útil a lo largo de su vida para
ayudarles a cumplir con su propósito
fruto de esto de algunas otras
experiencias
hace un tiempo cree lo que llamo una
matriz de resiliencia con cuatro grandes
cuadrantes y cuatro grandes preguntas
que pueden ayudarnos tal vez
a transformar
la adversidad en aliada la primera
pregunta dice que necesito aceptar para
extraer lo bueno de esta experiencia
actitud de cambio la segunda el segundo
cuadrante con la actitud de persistencia
dice cuando todo mejor en el futuro
qué utilidad podría tener esta
experiencia para mí el tercer cuadrante
la actitud de desarrollo dice qué
capacidades podría ayudarme a
desarrollar el hecho de estar
atravesando esta situación de dificultad
y el cuarto cuadrante el de actitud de
aprendizaje dice que he aprendido y en
qué ha mejorado mi vida por el hecho de
atravesar esta dificultad
antes os conté la historia de adán
en que deriva aunque derivó la historia
de adán adam a día de hoy trabaja
ayudando a personas en el mundo
empresarial principalmente a desarrollar
su inteligencia emocional directivos
directivas profesionales personas
organizaciones a conocerse mejor
entenderse mejor gestionarse mejor
conocer y comprender mejor a los demás
gestionar mejor las relaciones
y si alguno lo intuía pues si la
historia de adán es mi historia
adam es el nombre que me puso un maestro
oriental con el que trabajé hace mucho
porque una de las cosas
qué género mi gran first step
superar el síndrome del hermano sano es
que me convirtió en un buscador
necesite encontrar recursos para manejar
las turbulencias internas que van
sucediendo en mi vida
y descubrir
también el poder que tenemos los seres
humanos cuando conectamos unos con otros
y la enorme satisfacción que reside en
dedicar tu vida a sumar un granito de
arena de algún modo como se da a la vida
de los demás
hay dos grandes aprendizajes que me dejó
mi hermana grabados a fuego
y que me han resultado muy útiles a lo
largo de la ciudad
el primer aprendizaje es este que dice
hay cosas en la vida que por mucho que
no me gusten
no dependen de mí no puedo controlar y
no puedo cambiar por eso es importante
que elija aceptarlas porque la
aceptación del iberá para poder destinar
mi atención y recursos y mi energía a
aquello que yo sí puedo cambiar
no lo que no
enfocarte en lo que tú puedes hacer no
en lo que no puedes y el otro gran
aprendizaje que me grabó a fuego mi
hermana
es este que dice aunque hay cosas que yo
no puedo cambiar
hay gente que mataría por los recursos
de los que dispongo es mi
responsabilidad es tu responsabilidad
como ser humano tratar de sacar el
máximo partido a lo que tienes es muy
fácil
en nuestra atención se vaya hacia todo
lo que nos falta todo lo que no tenemos
todo lo que no podemos cambiar
y caer en la trampa del victimismo
pero es nuestra responsabilidad como
seres humanos
cambiar la mirada para apoyarnos en todo
eso que si tenemos
y como con eso poder avanzar hacia lo
mejor que podamos
esta es mi hermana esther recientemente
prácticamente ha perdido toda la
movilidad ahora tiene 39 años
recientemente le concedieron una silla
de ruedas nueva para poder desplazarse
me gustaría que os fijáis en su cara
recibir lo que viene con gratitud con
ilusión
yo lo único que puedo hacer es darle las
gracias
por tener a alguien en mi vida
que constantemente
me muestra el camino
no siempre es fácil
pero muestra el camino
siempre me gusta acabar cualquier
conferencia
leyendo un poema
juntos todos juntos suave tranquilos
este es un poema que escribí
precisamente hace unos años después de
vivir una situación de adversidad
con mi pareja
una situación de desafío y de ese
desafío surgió una visión clara
y quise plasmar la en este poema así que
me gustaría invitaros a que juntos el
silencio no en silencio suave podamos
leerla juntos a la de una a la de dos a
la de tres y dice
he aprendido a dejarme guiar por la
sabiduría de la vida a confiar en lo que
me propone pues ella sabe lo que
necesito a reconocer que cuanto más me
pide
y agradecer el regalo de poder elegir
esforzarme y he aprendido
que el esfuerzo me hace
libre libre como ser humano
muchísimas muchísimas
[Aplausos]